fue un ataque que conmocionó a francia y
al mundo entero días después de
conocerse por internet dos asaltantes de
19 años se unieron para atacar y matar a
un sacerdote de 85 años el padre ya
camel fue degollado mientras impartía
una misa en su iglesia del noroeste de
francia los autores de los hechos ya
estaban bajo sospecha y vigilancia de la
policía uno de ellos llevaba incluso una
pulsera electrónica después de que las
autoridades descubrieran que intentaba
viajar a siria pero ambos consiguieron
eludir la vigilancia tras asesinar al
sacerdote los atacantes murieron cuando
intentaban salir de la iglesia ahora
seis años después comienza en parís el
juicio contra tres presuntos cómplices
de todo un atentado no es sólo algo que
ocurre en un momento dado está lo que
ocurre antes y después antes de un
atentado hay personas que aportan los
medios que alientan el atentado un éxito
los tres hombres que según los fiscales
conocían el plan son acusados por
participar en una conspiración criminal
terrorista como defensa
2 aseguran que son chivos expiatorios un
cuarto hombre será juzgado en ausencia
se cree que rachid qásim murió en un
ataque con drones cerca de mosúl hace
cinco años y se le acusa de haber
elegido el objetivo haber aconsejado y
animado a los atacantes
es un propagandista en telegram lavaba
el cerebro y convencía a los jóvenes
franceses para que actuaran en casa se
espera que el juicio dure cuatro semanas